his abuse got so he got so confident
with the abuse and the level of abuse
that he could impose upon me
um I would be invited to his house and
so would another boy abuse one turn over
and beat the other and that's how
confident he was in being able to abuse
young boys still knowing that even
though somebody was present in the room
that they wouldn't say anything
[Music]
start kind of at the beginning when did
you start playing football
oh I started playing football
probably when I was
three or four and discovered just
naturally that I had an ability to play
my earliest memories of running around
with a ball my dad's adult friends not
being able to take the ball from me I
loved it I just I felt I was good at it
I was able to do things that other
people couldn't do and carry the ball
and play with the ball in a way that
just naturally came to me
I was from that point just out playing
with a ball until my dad found a junior
side for me when I was about eight my
dad apparently been approached by this
person on the side of the pitch who'd
been interested in in scouting me and
asking me to go and play for them
it introduced himself as a Northwest
Regional Scout for Manchester City
and that he could offer the opportunity
to want to go to play for him and also
to possibly get trials and an
opportunity to go to play for Manchester
City as a club
um
sort of beyond the small boys Wildest
Dreams really and I was just you know
playing in a small town with a an
absolutely no name Junior side of no
real ranking or ability and then this
guy came along and
and sort of offered a different a life
really from it
um and so it was it was exciting
and how old were you at this point I was
about 9 10.
and so did you then join this new club
under the guide of this coach yeah
um he asked me to go for a trial to see
how it fit in with the players he
already had
um I think I said it to two trials and
then he asked me to go and play uh with
his side and yeah his name was the coach
his name was Barry bannell
at that time everybody viewed him as a
star maker he was very charismatic
uh handsome athletic chap very talented
at football himself and he was seen to
be someone that had a lot of influence
in the game that could you know make it
happen for you could recommend that you
you were a good enough player and get
you that opportunity to uh potentially
get to sign affiliate Schoolboy
um forms with a club so it's usually
admired
um and um
people really flocked to towards him in
order to get those opportunities to play
um at a higher level and played for him
for about three three and a half years
um very successfully you know we're very
very successful side we were banned from
one league for being too good
um I remember we beat one side 37 nil
I'd regularly score Double Hat Tricks or
more
you know scoring 40 out 50 goals a year
um and in the football side of it was
was extremely enjoyable it was um
it was excellent standard except there
was another side
to playing for him that um I think now
is a bit more widely known but at the
time was probably one of football's
worst Kept Secrets
um and that is that he was a prolific
pedophile
the first time you abused can you talk
about what happened and how you were
feeling at that time it was it was at
his shop uh in in furnace veil in a
video shop that he owned
um
whilst watching a uh
I think it was American wheel from
London
um horror movies and
snuff movies as they were
um
things that would get you scared and
terrified were one of his tactics for
huddling up close and and starting that
low level of abuse
um there's a precursor to further things
to come
um
and I can certainly remember that video
shop
in detail and I think my mind is
focused on those elements
as opposed to what actually happened as
a
as a mechanism for survival and um
coping
really
one distinct thought
and
it's not about the actual abuse the acts
of abuse
um
I think you know you often hear this
phrase of fight or flight
and actually the most common response in
that type of situation is a reaction or
a response called flop
which means you've just been able to do
anything
and you shut down your brain shuts down
the the human body and brain is an
incredible thing that can protect us in
a way
that I don't think we really properly
understand and they'll focus on the
actual acts of abuse with something
really that
my brain's never allowed me to do but I
can say that after that first time
um I remember thinking how desperately I
wanted to get out of there
but I'd have to wait till the next day
till after the game until my dad came to
pick me up to be able to go home
and I remember going home
and trying to make everything as normal
as possible as if nothing had happened
and you were so young were you aware of
kind of what was happening to you was a
was bad or were you just I I I I knew it
wasn't it was something I'd never
experienced I was uh pre-pubescent
um I hadn't had girlfriends I ran around
with boys play football I had friends
that were girls and growing up with
friends that were girls but they were
mates
um the idea of sex or sexuality hadn't
even entered my head at that point and
so I was just incredibly confused I knew
it didn't feel right or or something I
enjoyed I was comfortable with
but other than that because it was so
confusing I really didn't know what to
say
or how to say something
or who to say something to
I remember thinking after the second
time I went back
and it happened again and got more
severe
I remember thinking to myself
I'm thinking I've got to tell somebody
but how do I
explained to people
that this has happened more than once
why did I go back
and I didn't think I'd be believed
because
if I come back
maybe it was my fault or I was in some
way responsible and it was something
that somebody would question
and every time I looked for a reason to
say something
I found that
in the environment I was in that there
wasn't a place or a person that I could
speak to
and so
I think it was a matter of
thinking Survival how how do I carry on
and cope and that the simple matter of
becoming shutting down my emotions and
effectively becoming a very emotionally
blunt
um person and then it'd be a matter of
putting on a mask
and going about the Daily Business and
um
I was grateful for the for the normality
of of getting up going to school going
to lessons and doing the ordinary things
um and that's what I focused on
um to try and avoid
just thinking about what happened or
what might happen again really you
mentioned that the abuse kind of spanned
a period of about three and a half years
how did it progressively get worse from
those lower levels of abuse
very quickly from from
um touching to low-level abuse the
masturbation onto oral sex onto full
buggery it was a matter of
weeks a couple of months as soon as he
knew that he was had control of me to
one degree he would escalate to the next
and that happened very quickly and once
it had escalated it then maintained
itself on all levels of abuse any
opportunity to which he could take one
of the things that benell did
was that he insisted Not only was I own
did I only play for his club and no
other
but that I stopped all other social
activities
so I played a musical instrument I had
social friends and social groups I
wasn't allowed to go and have music
lessons not allowed to have girlfriends
not allowed to have social groups go out
and party or birthdays it was all a
distraction from football but what that
meant was I had no experience of what
you'd considered a normal childhood
development through early teens you know
the stuff where we we get girlfriends or
boyfriends and we experiment with drugs
or drink or social activities and we
learn where that that social line is I
had no experience of that because I had
no comparisons against what was normal
this was my normal
and that's all I know didn't take long
for
him to
see
how or what he could get away with
abusing myself with
um when that started it escalated very
very quickly
um from what you call low level abuse to
the most serious uh levels of abuse I
certainly was one of the people that he
abused more regularly
um
you know I I was there pretty much every
weekend every school holiday I missed a
lot of school he took me abroad he took
me away to Butler into various places
for about three three and a half years
and uh you know his abuse got so he got
so confident with the abuse and the
level of abuse that he could impose upon
me that for a at least a couple of those
years if not longer
um I would be invited to his house and
so would another boy and there may be
others but regularly myself and this one
or the boy were invited
um and he would have us both sleep in
his bed and abuse us both abuse one
turnover and abuse the other and that's
how confident he was in being able to
abuse young boys still knowing that even
though somebody was present in the room
that they wouldn't say anything
and you mentioned that he would take you
away on holidays into Butlins it was
that kind of under the guise of football
team bonding
mostly he took me where wherever he
wanted whenever my parents would allow
which was pretty much every weekend all
weekend pretty much all I remember going
home to just collect clothes in the
summer holidays you know six weeks or so
um and so he would just take me wherever
and whenever he wanted during that
period where he abused me
I spent a lot of time with him he wanted
to take me to America
um the very last year I was playing for
him my parents thankfully put their foot
down and said that regardless of cost
they wouldn't let me go because he was
going for two or three weeks so it was a
chunk of time
um
and I know that he would have absolutely
taken advantage of me whilst he was away
and goodness knows if anybody else might
have um I know that he's certainly
established contacts and business out
there after that
the point did the abuse stop him was
that when it stopped was that the last
time you saw venel
yeah it stopped very abruptly
um it was about 14. we turned up for a
game and
um we were all gathered around then he
literally announced okay that's it uh
we're disbanding
and it was to everybody's shock
um and bemusement nobody really
understood where this had come from or
why at that moment in time would it
suddenly be folded
because at 14 was the year 1314 that was
the age that you signed Associated
Schoolboy forms with any big clubs so
for him to be a scout to pushing you
through to get to that stage to just
stop six months before that critical
point seemed very bizarre and odd
but he just basically said there's
nothing that he could do anymore for us
and that was the end of it
and then there was nothing
and so I needed to fill this great big
hole
um
and I did that really quite successfully
um with alcohol and recreational drugs
and that that that replaced the
emotional void
that I had from leaving football and the
anger and the frustration and the
negative emotions I felt the impacted
what happened to me it was
so great and I and I I wasn't yet at an
age where I was able to reflect on what
happened in a positive way and learn and
progress from it that I was just really
coping as best I could
was it still your secret through this
time as well um yeah I I hadn't told
anybody at all uh and I didn't tell a
soul I didn't indicate it there was a uh
a girlfriend while I was at school that
one time at home I broken down crying
saying you know I felt terrible and then
I stopped it I didn't even go close to
saying who what where or why I was just
I got upset the only other time that I'd
spoken about it was much later on when I
moved to London
um and uh my partner and I got together
and when we were looking to consider it
being a long-term relationship
through various conversations this
subject came up and we'd started to
tentatively talk about what had happened
to me and that was
well I know when that was it was 1994
and I can reference that because that's
when the police first contacted me in
relation to
um seeing if I would prepare to give any
statements and evidence about what might
happen to me as a child and the landline
rang and I picked it up and it was uh
the Cheshire constabulary
who said that they'd been given my name
with a view that I might know something
about Barry Bonnell and that they
wondered if anything might have happened
as a child
um and would I want to say anything if
it had in that they had
um been in contact with a 13 year old
boy
um who had reported suspected abuse from
Bonnell whilst he was in America on tour
and this Boyd reported alleged abuse
that happened to him and would I
consider
given a supporting statement if there's
anything that I might know
the reason for saying something wasn't
about me and it never was
it was the fact that there was this 13
year old boy I was 25 26 age
that had just very recently suffered
this abuse and to avoid being re-abused
and made a complaint about what happened
and it broke my heart that that this was
still happening to all the boys but the
Clincher really was the fact that the
police said no one would come forward
and
corroborate this boy's story and I knew
from my own experience that that had
that had
to be wrong though there had to be other
people
um
I just felt if I was to say something
I'd hope
knowing there was a boy in the bed next
to me for two or three years
that somebody else would have the
courage to come forward and say
something on my behalf
how are you now I'm probably healthier
and better than I've ever been in my
life I've processed and will continue to
process these things on an ongoing basis
but process the majority of the things
that happen to me and have a far better
understanding of them through therapy
and counseling and speaking about this
and it in in a more positive light
and it's it's enabled me to grow
strength and confidence that
um my life isn't worthless it has some
meaning
um and from 2016 the fa and the PFA had
employed me in part because of my lived
experience and that's for any survivors
of abuse of any sort of abuse not just
sexual racial physical Financial
emotional abuse in football either
historically non-recently or currently
and even just
be an ear for survivors to be able to
help them understand that actually none
of this is their fault and that there
are things that they can tap into and
you know I I I'd highly recommend
anybody that's been through abuse of
this sort or any sort to speak to not
just somebody else but to try and seek
formal counsel and therapy because for
me it's really helped
from my experience
not been able to speak to anybody
feeling like it's only you in a silo
could be one of the most destructive
things that can happen to you and
um
having known people that haven't managed
to get through life and have
no longer with us
um
and those that have helped to continue
on
I would always say that it's always
worth speaking about it and having hope
to go forwards than feeling like you're
on your own because that's a terrible
place to be in something I hope we can
eradicate
sooner rather than later
I reconcile myself to the fact that you
know
um you can't always choose your life's
Destiny we like to think we're in
control of everything but often we're
not and uh certainly that part of my
life I didn't have any control over and
um it's one thing I tried to do now is
have agency over my own life and
understanding from it so if nothing else
we hope we learn from these experiences
please
[Music]
I felt like
defeated
when I lay down
because I just was hoping that you
wouldn't want to have sex with me